...
-Dans ce village,
ce n'est pas la religion..
..qui impose aux femmes d'être
voilées, mais uniquement..
..le respect des hommes qui les
entourent. L'émancipation est..
..un parcours de longue haleine
pour les femmes indiennes.
Surtout en région rurale,
comme ici, en l'Utta Pradesh,
..où les basses castes
sont majoritaires.
-Quel est votre nom ?
-Je n'ai pas de nom.
Je ne sais ni lire,
..ni écrire.
Alors que puis-je dire ?
Alors, qu'est-ce que
je vais parler politique ?
-Sans avoir jamais connu l'école,
Kavita a été mariée à 12 ans,
..bercée par
d'incessants discours.
-"Tu es une jeune fille.
Que vas-tu faire en étudiants ?
"Un garçon peut faire
quelque chose.
"Tu ne vas pas devenir magistrat,
ni employer. Fais donc..
"..le travail
que font les jeunes filles."
-Encouragée par une association,
elle lutte pour suivre des études.
Sans soutien, ni respect,
..elle trouve le courage de quitter
son mari et sa belle famille,
..et devient journaliste.
-Mon fils a fait un boulot.
Il a été payé 70 roupies,
au lieu de 80.
-Quel établissement ?
-Là-bas.
-Quel âge il a ?
-10 ans.
-Alors pourquoi
tu fais travailler ton fils ?
-Comment je pourrais faire
autrement ?
-C'est interdit par la loi. Tu dois
attendre qu'il ait au moins 12 ans.
Et ce serait même mieux
d'attendre 18 ans.
-Il y a toujours de tels
problèmes dans les villages.
-Oui, mais si on n'en parle pas,
on ne trouvera pas de solutions.
-Tout comme Kavita, Shanti
appartient à une caste inférieure.
-J'ai commencé mes études
à l'âge de 32 ans.
Avant, j'étais analphabète,
je ne connaissais rien.
J'ai fait mes études par moi-même,
j'ai rempli le formulaire..
..d'école primaire
et j'ai travaillé..
..à la maison.
C'est ainsi que j'ai avancé.
Alors, j'ai eu la connaissance,
j'ai commencé à sortir..
..et je me suis dit que ma vie
était bidon. Je n'allais pas vivre..
..à travers le nom de mon mari.
Alors, j'ai dit :
.."Vous ne me batterez plus.
Allez de votre côté."
-Shanti n'a pas gardé..
..de contact avec son mari.
Elle assume seule..
..la charge de ses enfants
et petits-enfants..
..et son métier d'aujourd'hui,
celui de journaliste.
Kavita, Meera,
..Shanti et les autres,
..ont dû se battre
pour concrétiser leur rêve.
Elles ont créé..
..leur propre journal :
Khabar Lahariya.
La singularité..
..de l'équipe de rédaction
n'être composée que de femmes,
..toutes membres
de caste inférieure,
..comme les Intouchables.
"Khabar Lahariya" signifie..
.."Information qui font des vagues".
Le projet existe..
..depuis 2002,
..grâce aux soutiens
de Nirantar,
..un centre de lutte contre
la discrimination des femmes.
Dans la région d'Uttar Pradesh,
..où le taux d'illettrisme
dépasse la moyenne nationale,
..ce groupe d'une dizaine
de femmes..
..le combat chaque jour,
..en important l'information
à tous et toutes.
-Notre journal n'est pas lié
qu'aux femmes ou aux Intouchables.
On y trouve des informations
sur toutes les classes sociales.
Mais nous donnons priorité
aux castes inférieures exclus.
Cette fois,
..c'est bien imprimé.
-Meera travaille comme journaliste
depuis 6 ans. Epouse,
..mère de 5 filles,
et rédactrice en chef,
..elle assume toutes ses
responsabilités avec enthousiaste.
-La différence avec
les autres journaux,
..c'est qu'ils sont écrits en hindi,
la langue nationale.
Notre journal est lié
au monde rural..
..et tous ne savent pas..
..lire le hindi.
Le notre est écrit en grand
caractère dans leur dialecte.
Et les informations sont justes.
Ce que l'on nous dit,
on le retranscris tel quel,
..puis on fait des commentaires.
C'est ça qui nous différencie
des autres.
...
-Au quotidien,
..les journalistes parcourent..
..de longues distances à pied..
..ou en transport en commun,
car elles sont convaincues..
..qu'elles doivent voir
elles-mêmes..
..les situations qu'elles décrivent.
De nombreux journaux
se contentent souvent..
..d'un appel téléphonique.
Economie, social,
santé, politique, écologie...
A un rythme hebdomadaire,
le journal couvre tous les domaines.
-Personne n'a une carte
de ration alimentaire ?
Qu'avez-vous comme terre ?
-Nous, on a 5 lots de terre.
-80% de gens, ici, n'ont pas
la carte de ration alimentaire.
-Tout le monde l'a
mais personne ne peut en profiter.
Il ne faut surtout pas
être de basse caste.
-C'est pour les riches.
-Ce n'est pas pour les pauvres.
-Une fois, on a écrit un article
concernant un village.
Là-bas, il y avait un mariage dans
une famille de castes supérieures.
Avant le mariage,
il n'avait pas évoqué la dot.
Et le jour du mariage, la famille
du marié a exigé une dot.
Alors, la famille de la mariée,
avec l'aide des villageois,
..a enfermé les gens de la famille
dans l'école et ils l'ont battu.
Notre équipe est allée..
..enquêter sur place..
..et on a publié cette histoire
à la Une.
Le marié avait demandé
un poste de télévision.
Alors on a titré : "Il veut épouser
une femme ou un téléviseur ?"
Alors,
les gens se sont mis en colère :
.."Nous sommes de castes..
"..supérieures et on se moque
de nous ? C'est quoi, ce titre ?"
-Alors qu'elles se déplacent..
..pour leur enquête,
..les journalistes vendent
elles-mêmes leur journal.
Plus de 300 villages couverts,
..4 300 exemplaires..
..lus chacun
par une dizaine de lecteurs.
Pas loin de 50 000 lecteurs,
..rien que pour
ce petit groupe de femmes.
-Au début, quand on dénonçait
quelque chose dans notre journal,
..les gens nous défiaient,
on a même reçu des menaces de mort.
Alors, on avait peur. Ils disaient
qu'on raconte n'importe quoi.
Quand on vendait le journal,
on était très gênées.
Les gens se demandaient si
on faisait ça juste pour l'argent.
Alors, on avait mal au coeur.
On se disait
que notre travail n'était..
..peut-être pas bien..
..pour être traité ainsi.
Maintenant, on se dit que si
on s'était laissée influencer,
..on aurait fait du surplace.
-Elles font un bon travail.
Elles vont de maison en maison,
de village en village.
Les grands journalistes, eux,
ne se rendent pas là-bas.
Ils restent seulement
dans les villes.
Ici, l'information vient
de petits endroits. Ainsi,
..les fonctionnaires administratifs
sont mieux au courant des problèmes.
Après, libre à eux
de résoudre ses problèmes.
La balle est dans leur camp.
-Confrontés aux problèmes
de la population, il arrive..
..aux journalistes de faire
le relais avec l'administration,
..comme la banque locale
où elles enquêtent aujourd'hui.
Des gens se plaignent de n'avoir
pu y effectuer des opérations.
-Comment réagissez-vous ?
C'est vrai..
..ou pas ?
-Il y a beaucoup de problèmes avec
les gens qui ne sont pas éduqués.
Des chefs de village devraient
leur dire avec quel papier venir.
Moi, je n'ai pas le temps.
Il faudrait faire
passer l'information.
-Connaissez-vous notre journal ?
-Bien sûr, je le reçois..
..et je le lis souvent.
Je l'apprécie, je la connais bien
et j'apprécie son travail.
Elle fait sérieusement son travail.
Je lui ai promis de collaborer
et d'apporter mon aide..
..autant que possible.
...
-Ces informations elles
sont ramenées de partout..
..après tant de luttes.
Alors quand on les lit,
..ça nous fait plaisir.
J'aime bien ce journal,
..comme la plupart des gens.
-Et avec ceci,
nos femmes sont en train d'évoluer.
Notre société, qui était opprimée,
est en train de s'améliorer.
Le pouvoir de réflexion et
la capacité de nos droits augmente..
..et ça avance grâce au journal.
-On parle de nous à la télévision,
..dans les journaux.
Autrefois, comme on est
de castes inférieures,
..les gens importants ne nous
invitaient pas parmi eux.
Aujourd'hui, ils nous proposent
de nous asseoir sur des chaises.
Quand on va à la police, dans une
banque ou d'autres administrations,
..on nous reconnaît
comme journalistes femmes.
Aujourd'hui, tout le monde
nous respecte beaucoup.
-On aimerait répandre le journal
dans d'autres districts..
..et dans d'autres Etats.
-J'ai réussi en luttant..
..et je continue à le faire.
Je suis en train
de donner la réplique.
-Kavita, Meera, Shanti
et les autres..
..n'oublieront jamais ce jour..
..où le premier ministre indien
leur décerna le Prix Chameli Devi,
..les consacrant journalistes
les plus remarquables de l'année.